court what'd you do with your first
major paycheck that came in
i love knowing that you know like you
get your first paycheck and you're like
[ __ ] what do you spend it on
you know what i bought i went at like i
uh the first time i really spent a [ __ ]
ton of money on myself this is so sad
this tells you how white trash i am
right
are you ready for this yeah i walked in
to a best buy
i walked into a best buy and i bought
ten thousand dollars worth of dvds this
is no
yeah
i still
have them they could even print me out a
receipt they had to give me a computer
printout
of everything that i bought like it was
[ __ ] low rent dude it was so i was
walking around i had five
[ __ ] shopping carts and all of my
friends before i knew they were like you
want this one i was like
[Applause]
so i love that
you're like the original night
everything i went i went
very similar what would you do oh i did
i did the same [ __ ] thing except more
like with music cds you know like
i would you know like but i don't
remember that being like the first the
first thing you've never asked me this i
don't think and you're the first thing
the big
expensive thing that i bought i just
think i [ __ ] i don't remember it i
like bought a big fridge and a lot of
booze i mean i would go on some crazy
grocery you know once i had an apartment
okay you get your first
not not jack has one
but like maybe then where you made the
most and you're like [ __ ] dude
i mean i don't know i mean i ended up
buying a rolex in 2003.
the rolex yeah i mean dude it's kind of
embarrassing like that's cool everyone
never had a roll like i ended up like
losing it in the pcp blackout
i literally blacked out on pcp i have no
idea for all i know i gave it away
no idea
yeah if anybody listening has steve's
first rolex maybe just
he'll sign it or something i think i
think somebody knows what the [ __ ]
happened to somebody somebody else knows
i think i know
you think you know i i
suspect i suspect that i know but uh in
any case so um
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats